Pixar is moving on words and critics are
pretty much on board reviews are coming
in for Pixar's latest offering and
general consensus is that while it may
not be quite on par with some of the
studio's classics it still packs plenty
of laughs charm and eye-popping
animation onward tells a story of two
elven brothers who inhabit a once
magical world that seems to have lost
all of his luster together they embark
upon an epic quest to discover if there
is any magic left in the world magic
might help them resurrect their departed
dad long enough for them to give him a
proper goodbye the flick is directed by
Dan Scanlon from a screenplay he
co-wrote with Jason Headley and Keith
bunin Marvel Cinematic Universe alumni
Tom Holland stars as Ian Lightfoot while
Chris Pratt lends his voice to Bali
Lightfoot among the supporting cast a
Julia louis-dreyfus Octavia Spencer
Mary gasps Ali Wong and Tracey Ullman
whose folks are introduced the world to
the Simpsons in 1987 even the flicks
that don't live up to the greatest
entries in Pixar's catalog are still
going to be a cut above your average
animated fare and the majority of
critics felt that onward was a perfectly
fine animated comedy with the requisite
amount of heart string tugging also
obviously it looks spectacular nobody
ever accused Pixar of cutting corners
when it comes to animation Kristy putco
of IGN wrote Scanlan has crafted an
adventure that gleefully flies high with
his fantasy elements yet never loses
touch with his grounded family tale plus
it has a sensational pace that keeps the
adventure rollicking and keeps the
audience on the edge of their seats a
terrifically entertaining tale with
humor hearts and illusions are sure to
delight fantasy fans many reviewers were
a bit more reserved in their praise
alluding to um words failure to hit the
storied heights of Pixar's greatest
while still acknowledging his strengths
CBR Cynthia Vinnie said onwards simply
doesn't have the same emotional dramatic
or comedic power as the best of Pixar
it's a minor entry in the Pixar Canon a
perfectly pleasant way to pass the time
however although onward received kudos
for the performances of Holland Pratt
and Spencer in particular and for
hitting those familiar emotional notes
we crave from Pixar den of geeks David
crow remarks whatever its shortcomings
onward is still an amusing Lee clever
piece of family entertainment with a
tangible hearth of the center of his
book of spouse this might be Pixar on an
off day
but even that it feels like spending
quality time with a dear loved one a
fairly strong contingent of
viewers for quite a bit less forgiving I
see you've brought sustenance for our
adventure no it's garbage for the trash
can
they tend it to peg on word is
half-baked too long and well extremely
weird in an off-putting way Mick LaSalle
of the San Francisco Chronicle wrote on
what looks great and as a couple of
strong scenes on the Crippin and even
ingenious births as a whole the movie is
misbegotten over long and all together
and convincing as a story of familial
love long before it's 114 minute running
time has elapsed in his over status
welcome Mike Ryan of aprox was even less
kind this is a movie about two kids
resurrecting their dead dad's crotch and
it's just the weirdest thing at one
point in this movie I literally tried to
get emotional if I'm watching nothing I
can make myself get there watching
onwards I couldn't do it every time I
felt even a hint of emotion here comes a
walking crotch other reviewers slapped
on word with labels such as undercooked
flattened and diluted and
disappointingly pedestrian the consensus
of on words negative notices was summed
up nicely by Josh Spiegel of / film
onward is OK
the problem with onward is that Pixar's
original films are incredible okay it's
simply just not good enough
the majority of critics though found
onward to be a satisfactory if
unspectacular addition to pig sales
catalog you can see for yourself whether
the flick hit your own personal mark
when it drives into theatres on March
6th check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]